es ist die höhle wo ich am anfang
gestorben bin zweimal das wiedersehen
das wiedersehen ich keine ahnung
redstone vielleicht ja
redstone war fred ja das heißt jetzt
habe ich durch und ich hab mi tor
entdeckt was ist das nicht etwas bringt
apatit schreibt dass man die kommentare
was bringt apatit fünfter mito gta lux
und agyness jetzt erstmal mit dann habe
ich auf 146 das irgendwann mal braucht
so also erstmal das wässerchen hier rein
ach so ich wollte ja meine mining titel
an kurzbesuchen was unternehme ich
natürlich auch gleich noch mal ein
eimerchen lover mit folge die langgeht
die schon nach 15 minuten mit ihr gut in
der zeit hier also 20 man muss sich da
erst mal den talent war und fressen bis
man dann zu den zauberstäben kommen da
kann ich mir alle zauberstäbe erforschen
und da ist nämlich schon zurückgekommen
weil waiting for you
er hat ihr silber mitgebracht redstone
order über ein steak redstone
mitgebracht das echt nicht schlecht
feiert perfekt wie perfekt blieb alles
mitnehmen alles mit dem
soll ich nehme jetzt erstmal hier wieder
paar ärzte mit falls jetzt zwar nicht
was davon wertvoll ist und was nicht und
mussten mit muss mir schon wieder neue
kiste machen beendet ja manche ist es
einfach mit diamanten so ne ne spezielle
rezepte für musste gucken also jetzt
habe ich hier so ein natürlich mal
hierhin für weiteren plunder bricht ein
mba eigentlich das ist auch für dieses
magische zeug das kann ich zumindest
entzaubern weiß ich wie weit das war
nötig ist aber es geht
das ist schon durch dass es durch dass
es nicht das ist durch so kann ich
wieder einschmelzen so herrlich alter
also die meinen titel echt fantastisch
so dass jetzt einfach mal seine untere
ebene damit ich hier so ein bisschen
näher zum redstone komme vielleicht auch
meine ersten diamanten hier findet so
tim wurde jetzt auch abgehärtet meinberg
produkten irgendwas los ton und
eisenberg produkts tag der frist
irgendwie alles irgendwie mit bergbau zu
tun hat automatisch auch ärzte auch
unser was alles ja ärzte kloster so was
halt okidoki werde ich mir weitermachen
silber rasse und der block julia penner
den penner meinen papa getötet
ich schaue mal vielleicht kann ich beide
eigentlich stopp eingeben wenn ich dir
jetzt direkt mit einem lover einmal
fülle dann marschiert die direkt los und
das will ich nicht will ich erstmal voll
machen damit sie auch wirklich ganz nach
unten geht
das rating von fuel ich kann gar nicht
stoff machen aber ich kann es abbauen
was kann ich da musst du neu anfangen
ich sowieso falsch rum jetzt wieder
genau das ist die höhle wo ich am anfang
gestorben bin zweimal das wiedersehen
da es wieder sehr gut aber hier schon
mal redstone nicht da hats wieder sieht
da bin ich schon zweimal dann gestorben
alter muss jetzt aufpassen gibt die mit
8000 lava gespeichert und dann musste
der sich abbauen
das war natürlich ein armutszeugnis hier
ich hatte gerade kassel lag und ich dann
vor der lava das bloß auswahl dieser
höhlen dieser höhle sammeln die ganzen
und ex kwl 10 liegen sie mal los
minister ich werde hier einfach jetzt
nach unten gehen kann ich hier ist lara
udo musik blocken
der crc die kassenärzte kaputt der cr-z
so das ist ja einer seite werde ich dann
später von filz soll erste machen die
geht jetzt hier runter oder zurzeit
keine ahnung
nach der weiß ja gar nicht dass unten
war da geht jetzt alles so ab ok damit
man weiter unten ist macht das schon
ganz in ruhe ich werde noch eine zweite
kiste dransetzen
ich arbeite hier knapp über der lava
raid haben wir hier silber zu ihren job
hat die silver trust i want to go
der rechtsanwalt zurückgeben können hier
ist genug normalmensch upgrade ich glaub
ich weiß nicht welche um eine spitzhacke
verzaubern oder oder lieber ein schwert
ich werde eigentlich bringt nichts
also ich meine die mobs kriegt auch
somit zwei stehen kaputt also ich finde
verzauberte wieso muss ich sage nicht
mehr so wirkungsvoll wegen des wetters
ich meine wenn ich glück habe und so auf
einer spitzhacke dann wäre schon gut
glück ist wirklich das einzige was geht
und haltbar und es liegt vielleicht
glück und sind die einzigen beiden
sachen wo ich sagen okay alles klar die
könnte man noch irgendwie gebrauchen
kann man sich halt allerdings nicht
aussuchen das ist halt so dass bilder so
ist eisen das haben wir dann silber zu
gold das enorme touren challenges to
broadcast über die lava heute aber mal
die chest aus für die meiler mit jeder
mehr so ein upgrade gemacht einfach
wirklich gut so schnell
jetzt haben wir hier mit top liste der
geht hier unter der sammelt sich das
schönen wolf das ist fantastisch dass
wir oben genau wir wollten zaubern
dafür bin ich hier zaubert wasser rein
und genau wir brauchen wie viel wissen
wir brauchen den mito man sechs lux 4
feuer
ich bin hier weiter im alten abbauen
einfach ganz stumpf
das jetzt keine obsession wie ein
skelett auf der karte eine ganze kiste
voll mit kabel gemacht muss das wirklich
sein werde es ein bisschen kommt es dann
einfach abbauen damit ich gleich was hat
und bei den weg weiter zu bauen sehr gut
also warum schlafen gehen an gewisse
oder in der höhle zombie meiner mutter
so war ich ja kein garnichts abartig
aber wirklich nichts das heißt wir haben
jetzt wir brauchen vielleicht hast du
das mit märkten 446 fackel 44 feuer und
aus vielen normal
ok ich hab' schon sehr gut 1 2 3 4 5 6
wer das jetzt verzaubern sollten war
etwas herausbekommen was fein ist man
schon auf das nächste rezept zu finden
können ja wohl ja wisst nicht was es ist
aber ich will sagen aber noch mehr nie
tor fast immer so wie man in der höhe
lesen
dann immer ein paar sachen verkehr bloss
12 456 sich die harry potter stars sogar
gefällt mir richtig gut dass das weg
aber hier mit ihren fackeln und auch so
ich habe jetzt endlich so viel ipv6 rats
und setzt noch nicht viel aber die
zombies die stirn eine busse woher
wissen wir dass ich unten bin die mich
etwas bringt nikolic liegt vorliegt ich
weiß nicht aber mit dem server mit schon
wieder so ein ding ich tue jetzt beide
mal hier rein und das war doch der jazz
und politik davon haben wir immer noch
nicht genug das heißt wir brauchen waren
feuer und prägte das haben wir auch hier
oder beim und blauen stein das haben sie
direkt herausgefunden und in diesen
stein bekommt man glaube ich aus im
kabel sich das richtig hinbekommt mann
aus stein
das heißt ich meine dieses element
bekommen aus kabel kabel können wir
gerne so viel wie wir wollen hier
verschwinden alle medium neuer zauber
was kann der damit kann ich
damit kam ich auch so mir wieder was
waren aus dem biss und polizei 33 und
das hatte ich kraft ich bin richtig
harry potter ich mir wie bei professor
snape im sommer lang unterricht los
potter kräften sie direkt unter das
hätte auch schiefgehen können
ich habe meinen platz da war ja das
nächste hingezaubert das eigentlich ganz
geil diese mischmasch dinger die ihr
führen uns häufig zu den nächsten
zaubersprüchen und genau deswegen ist es
glaube ich auch gemacht
1 2 3 1 2 black black black jack black
ich kann ja gar nicht hochgehen er weil
es dunkel ist wird gerne meine bienen
mal checken
ja ich gehe jedoch so wirr aus japan
ihren zweck gesammelt das sollte passen
denke ich ja
stein element alles klar darüber ob so
machen wenn so viel politik gibt es
nicht so wertvoll
wir sonst noch heute wollte ist es nicht
dass sie so nicht raten es fleisch auch
feiere auch nicht mitkommt es hat nicht
gereicht
und ach so wir haben exchanges
unglücklich über die nächste party oder
wie das auch heil darunter alter [ __ ]
ich jetzt schon so insofern situation
vorstellen könnte es heftig
das ist echt rollen richtige höhle
ich glaube ich muss ja mein im tor ist
einfach verwenden so und der nächste
zauber ist der vorstand powderhorn name
sagt es schon ich kann danach vision
ganz bezaubernd ja was mir sehr viel
bling
herr vorkommenden ist noch irgendetwas
hier mit steini steini macht nicht mit
wirklich okay mit der fackel auf jeden
fall denke ich eisen allerdings und ich
wusste ich wusste es irgendwie selber
zusammen und ich habe schon eine idee
und zwar hier vorne etwas wertvolles
hier und zwar das etwas wertvolles das
vielleicht kein kind ist da nicht so
wertvoll der aber also ich brauche sagt
häufig ist in malawi hat ja auch diese -
genau das hat mir schon gedacht weil das
ist dir so metall artig metall edel und
tausch mit basic transmutation jetzt
kommen wir der sache doch näher
was hat mir das gebracht ich kann
basic transmutation ich kann zwei
medaillen 2 gold lage zu machen
dafür hat ihn hier und die latte der hat
acht videos das heißt ich kann zwei iron
nuggets und ein lapis lazuli in zwei
goldwaage zu machen wie schlecht das
werde ich auch gleich mal machen
ich bin immer noch weiter haben im erz
abbauen weil das kreuz ehrlich gesagt
wirklich nichts machen
meist einfach ich habe gesagt ich mach
das cap potter muss zaubern als 22
goldwaage kronen ich jetzt aber noch so
viel mit wie ich in mein inventar passt
hat tatsächlich geht es wieder voran
hier ist stimmt mit drin ja wenn man das
hier bei m mit salam war ausgereizt
denke ich vielleicht ein bisschen stein
dazu nicht stein kommt nicht vor ich die
wollten
gut kommt auch nicht vor feuer könnte
dazugehören nein es ist auch nicht
ersichtlich
lorenz ist das andere
die thora das ist lied das auch einfach
mal mit was kann ich nochmal lois staub
ich kann ein schild verbrennen toll dass
hier vielleicht noch dann das hier
flachsen bisschen einfach alles
irgendwie rein tun sagt zack zack zack
wo wir aufnahme wurde automatisch
angehalten
ja also muss ein verkaufsstart rücken
meiner fans kämpfen